il est responsable de 6000 nouveaux cas
de cancer chaque année en France le
papillomavirus dans le collimateur des
autorités de santé une campagne de
vaccination généralités va être lancée
dans les collèges annoncé Emmanuel
Macron on en parle avec la responsable
de la vaccination au CHU de Tours
bonsoir docteur zwa macaron vermeis voir
parler de cette campagne de vaccident
vaccination et d'abord les basiques
qu'est-ce que le papillomavirus et quels
sont les conséquences pour la personne
atteinte alors le papillomavirus en fait
ce sont les papillomavirus c'est une
famille de plusieurs types de virus les
papillomavirus donc des virus qui sont
transmissibles par voie sexuelle mais
c'est pas uniquement les rapports
sexuels mais c'est tout type de rapport
qui soit le contact à nos vaginaux ou
oraux et ces virus en fait on va tous se
décroiser dans notre vie 90% et des
hommes et des femmes croiseront ces
virus dans leur vie
arriveront à s'en débarrasser mais
parfois on va pas s'en débarrasser et
seront donc responsables de cancer et
donc comme vous l'avez dit 6000 cancers
par an que ça soit des cancers de la
gorge du cancer du col de l'utérus ou
des cancers
tout de suite ou peut-être plusieurs
années après non c'est ça le problème de
ce virus c'est-à-dire quand une fois
qu'on l'a on se rend pas compte
immédiatement parce qu'il va aller à
l'intérieur du cellule des cellules et
puis après on va développer le cancer
mais plusieurs années après donc dans
les 15 à 20 ans après avoir été
contaminé par ce virus parfois aucun
moyen de le détecter est-ce qu'il touche
plutôt les hommes les femmes ils
touchent les hommes et les femmes pour
le détecter faut faire des dépistages
donc chez les femmes ce sont les frottis
du col de l'utérus chez les hommes il y
a pas de dépistage généralisé donc
effectivement et puis pour les cancers
autres ben en fait on va le détecter une
fois qu'on est au stade de cancer comme
les cancers ORL alors cette campagne de
vaccination pour tous les élèves de
collège à partir de la rentrée élèves de
5e vaccination gratuite et soumise à
l'accord des parents ce qu'elle
permettra d'endiguer la maladie selon
vous aujourd'hui cette vaccination elle
est recommandée et remboursée par
l'assurance maladie à 65 % du tarif du
vaccin pour tous les jeunes entre 11 et
14 ans et avec un rattrapage jusqu'à 19
ans chez les femmes et jusqu'à 26 ans
chez les hommes ayant des rapports
sexuels avec les hommes il se trouve que
la couverture vaccinale reste faible en
France autour de 38% chez les filles et
6 à 10% chez les garçons les mauvais
élèves de l'Europe comme souvent au
vaccinologie
vaccin
al pendant recommandation à 60% dans
d'autres pays comme l'Australie par
exemple ils sont à 80% de couverture
vaccinale c'est efficace ils ont vu
effectivement le nombre de cancers du
col chuté d'une manière importante alors
est-ce que vous savez comment cette
campagne de vaccination va s’orchestrer
ce qu'il fera deux trois doses comment
ça va se passer
alors les recommandations aujourd'hui
entre 11 et 14 ans donc les classes de
5e sont dans cette tranche là c'est deux
doses à six mois d'intervalles donc du
coup pour être efficace il faut recevoir
ces deux doses à l'heure actuelle et
donc du coup comment cette campagne va
s'organiser dans les collèges nous
sommes effectivement en attente
d'éclaircissement sur le sujet mais
c'est une très bonne nouvelle ça va
permettre en fait à ceux qui ne font pas
la démarche pour se faire vacciner chez
le docteur d'avoir d'autres possibilités
de recevoir le vaccin bien sûr avec
l'accord des parents est-ce que ce
vaccin est sûr aujourd'hui on a beaucoup
de recul il y a des milliards de doses
qui ont été faites dans le monde et nous
n'avons pas d'effet indésirables
imputable au vaccin en dehors de la
douleur aussi d'injection il n'y a pas
de problématique particulière sur la
tolérance merci Docteur Zoa makaroun
vermeez nous avoir éclairé donc sur ce
vaccin et le papillomavirus merci
beaucoup merci à vous